Speaker 1: Let's go next to Mike from
Massachusetts. Mike from Massachusetts,
welcome to the program. What's on your mind?
Mike from Massachusetts, You've got to
accept my invitation to join the discussion.
Speaker 2: Sorry. Didn't know about
the except part. How you doing, David?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well, thank you.
Speaker 2: I don't have so much of a question,
but just kind of like an observation
on what your thoughts might be on it.
And I apologize if I have some panic getting
over, getting over a cold, but no problem.
So I actually watched recently while I was, you
know, had some downtime on the couch getting
over this cold. I watched a docu series on Netflix
called World War Two in Color. Pretty interesting.
And there was an episode dedicated at least
partly to the rise of the anti some anti-Semitic
policies in Germany. And like how that just how
that just kind of how that came to be because a
lot of times people ask themselves, you know, how
did the German people not see this coming? Yeah.
And what they do is what they described is
and I know people get tired of the comparison,
but I mean, it is strikingly similar to narratives
and things being said not just about Jews,
but other minorities in this country
today by the right. And, you know, I mean,
a lot of a lot of the a lot of the argument as
to why the German people never did anything is
because a lot of them just assumed things would
never go that far, quote unquote, you know,
they would never actually legalize persecution
and whatnot. And I just am curious, like, how you
think how you think the two situations compared
from today in America to them in the thirties.
Speaker 1: You know, this is so tough because
any time you delve into this, it's very hard
to avoid either being not concerned enough or
sounding hyperbolic and and and alarmist. Right.
So it's it's very, very difficult. So I'm going
to try to, like, speak as precisely as possible.
I don't think that circumstances for Jews in the
U.S. today. Are anything like circumstances for
Jews in pre-World War two Germany. I think
the starting points are very different.
I also think that we are seeing
a growth of a rhetoric about Jews
in the U.S. and that that rhetoric is more
acceptable than it's been for a long time,
as we can see. Sort of like in the reactions to
stuff Kanye said, where people going, listen,
Kanye is just kind of telling the truth
or whatever the case may be. That scares
me because it's the type of acceptance or or at
least disregard for the concern that was present
in pre-World War two, Germany. So, like, I'm I'm
not equivocating, but I'm just sort of saying,
like, the circumstances are different. But a lot
of the flippant attitude does seem similar. And I
do think we need to be very concerned about that.
Speaker 2: Right. And it's based on what the
documentary like talked about. It was like that
those attitudes, people thought like, we can have
these attitudes, like it's fine, but it's never
going to become policy until it becomes policy.
Absolutely. And it's just kind of
interesting that people kind of
feel like they could see these things
coming, but really, it's easier for
it to slip by than people like to think.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I completely agree with
you. I completely agree. And and the trick
is, if you go too alarmist, people dismiss
you. So what we need to do is find a way to
communicate the alarm in a way that's accurate,
but that doesn't get people to just tune it out.
Speaker 2: Right. I mean, and it's interesting,
like something else and this will be my last
point. I'll let you move on. But it's interesting.
Something else I learned from the documentary
was like, you know, the narrative of World War
Two is obviously, you know, America and Britain
and a few other allies fighting a courageous war
against just pure evil, like good evil, all the
all that all that stuff. But something interesting
I learned is that the Allies actually acquired a
ton of evidence against tons of Nazi officers who
participated in the Holocaust in exterminating
the Jewish population as best they could. Yeah.
And interestingly enough, there was actually a
while the American population was outraged by it.
There was actually a pretty large Semitic voice
in the U.S. government that pressured the rest of
the allies to drop charges against these people in
exchange for American financial aid following the
war. Yes. So it's just interesting that there
are things that that's a significant piece of
information I did not know until the other night.
And that's just like one of these things that
I feel like is important for
Americans to learn. But the
right would never want anyone to learn about them.
Speaker 1: Without a doubt. Without a doubt. Mike,
I appreciate the call. Okay.
Speaker 2: All right,
everyone. All right.
Speaker 1: There's Mike from Massachusetts